all right there is a new vaccine in town
and we've been monitoring the fda and
all of this
keeping track of how many doses are
going to get out i guess they're talking
about 5.9 to 6 million doses
within the next 48 hours on top of the
roughly 6 million of the pfizer vaccine
doses
that are out you normally cut that
number in half though with both of them
because
these are both uh two dose residues for
individuals whether they're spread
21 days or fewer days apart let's get
the read from christina coleman
following the significance of all of
this she's in los angeles christina
hi neil yeah great news here we just got
an update from operation warp speed
distribution has already begun with
syringe and needle kits
and the vaccine will arrive in states
starting on monday
and this couldn't come sooner with the
u.s regularly reporting more than 3
000 deaths a day and many hospitals
reaching their breaking points
nursing homes and healthcare workers are
the first to receive pfizer's vaccine
that was approved for emergency use
authorization
last week and about 1.1 million people
worldwide have received that vaccine
already
now modernist vaccine will add to this
fight against this deadly virus
modernist vaccine will be given to
people 18 years
and older in two doses and four weeks
apart
the company says its vaccine is 94.1
percent effective
at preventing symptomatic covalent 19
cases
and early data also indicates it might
protect vaccinated people from
asymptomatic infections as well and
unlike pfizer's vaccine which is also
highly effective against covid
modernist doesn't need to be stored in
super cold temps
making mass distribution less
challenging in rural areas
now despite this welcome news health
officials warn people
against letting their guard down
while this second vaccine from moderna
added onto pfizer
now allows us as a whole of america to
be on the offense
we are a long way from being finished
i join our health professionals in
urging americans to stay diligent in
their defense
wear a mask wash your hands and stay
socially distant
and after 20 million people could get
their first dose of one of these two
vaccines
by the end of the year neil
all right christina thank you very very
much